Speaker 1: I have told you now so many times
when Republicans are obsessed with saying
the left is doing X, we should at least explore
whether what they mean is we Republicans are
doing that very thing. New headline Republicans
fired after possible ballot harvesting operation
in Pennsylvania up. Oh, wait a second. Is this
the voter fraud they've been warning us about?
Check this out. This is a report from Pennlive
and the Philadelphia Inquirer. The fallout from
the discovery of a potential Republican ballot
harvesting operation in South Philly continued
Tuesday as two state party officials say two
state party staffers lost their jobs. The matter
became fodder for attacks in the Republican
primary for governor. And lawmakers on both
sides jockeyed to define just what the situation
said or didn't about voting by mail. Republican
Party officials have fired Seamus O'Donnell and
C.J. Parker, both of whom are affiliated with
the Republican Registration Coalition, the PAC
behind the South Philly mail ballot operation.
Prior to his termination, O'Donnell and the
PAC's former treasurer and Republican ward
leader in Northeast Philly worked as a field
organizer for the state party. Most recently
on the campaign of state Senate candidates Sam
Oropeza Parker, also a Republican ward leader,
worked as a personal aide to state party chair
Lawrence Tabish. Okay, they declined to comment.
Sources who describe the terminations said the
party's decision to cut ties with the two men
stemmed from an Enquirer story last week raising
questions about the PAC's work registering people
in South Philly to vote by mail. Listen to
this. The news organization found dozens of
Republican mail ballots for the May 17 primary
were being diverted to a P.O. box registered
to the Republican Registration Coalition. The
committee's chairman said he helped the voters
fill out ballot applications, inserting his P.O.
box on the form where voters would typically write
their home addresses. Though he maintained he was
doing this as a service to the voters, of course,
and intended to hand deliver the ballots once
they arrived. Many of the affected voters say they
don't remember applying to vote by mail and had
no idea why their ballots were going to Lens LRT
instead of directly to them. One said Len
Zloty delivered his ballot back to the city
once filled out, which would violate state
law now would violate state law. They've been
fired. They've not yet been charged with anything.
If they did this, it is arguably criminal. When we
say something violates state law, that means it's
a crime. At the minimum, we need an investigation.
But the most important thing here is they've
been talking about this voter fraud now for a
long time. They talked about it for six
months leading up to the 2020 election.
We found no evidence of voter fraud, fraud,
fraud, no evidence of voter fraud meant to or
succeeding at Joe, but helping Joe Biden steal the
election. But given that in the anecdotal cases
where we find this type of stuff, it's almost
exclusively Republican. Shouldn't we be exploring
Donald Trump's performance in 2020? Even
Donald Trump's performance in 2016 now?
Am I being facetious? I don't really know. I mean,
I'm not alleging without evidence that Trump and
Republicans committed voter fraud in 2020 and 2016
other than the people who were caught. Right. I'm
I'm actually being careful and responsible with
my speech. But when all the smoke is coming from
Republicans getting caught doing this stuff,
don't we at least need to ask the question
in the in the time that Republicans have been
saying, look at the fraud committed by Democrats,
which doesn't exist, shouldn't we at least
make sure that they haven't been committing
voter fraud, voter suppression, election fraud on
their side? Just a question and you can tell me
how you think it should be answered. On Monday,
May 30th, Memorial Day, we will be doing a
one day membership special. It is our midterm
membership special, trying to build the ranks
of membership as we head into a critical time for
the left. Hopefully it doesn't go terribly wrong.
I would love for you to sign up on that day.
We'll send out an email with a special coupon
code on Memorial Day to be notified. Just get
our newsletter at David Pakman dot com. Go to
David Pakman dot com. Sign up for the newsletter
and then you will be notified on Memorial Day
of how to avail yourself of this great
membership discount. The David Pakman Sh